ladies and gentlemen this time it here a
lot of talk shows do their big holiday
giveaways well we don't have the budget
of those other shows you imagine but
what we can do is we can give a prize to
one lucky audience member so let's hear
it for our first annual Conan holiday
giveaway spectacular
[Applause]
all right well this gentleman one lucky
audience member will receive our
incredible holiday prize and that prize
is going to Andy Devine all right here
it comes
not working Wow that's great
okay yeah come on okay it did it 18
times in rehearsal yeah it's just that
kind of bit it's gonna I was turning it
drunk yeah that's the kind of pain my
fault don't pull that up an editor sure
we will
and the prize is going to the person
seated in seat 6j congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
hey congratulations
that's fantastic what's your name Mary
Mary I believe it I I never win anything
well Mary that just changed because
tonight you've won two hundred and six
iPhones
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah well you got two hundred and six of
them beta hold on a second I'm I'm
confused why are you confused Andy well
I'm not sure that this is how this is
supposed to work I mean she just won two
hundred and six iPhone exams way at
first yeah okay but we have 206 people
in our audience
[Applause]
we can't afford to give everyone 206
iPhones we can't that's a lot of money
we can't afford that you just give
everyone one iPhone one iPhone No
that sounds that sounds like a pretty
crappy giveaway now but when you give
someone over 200 iPhones
that's something Mary's gonna remember
for the rest of her life aren't you Mary
yeah Andy you're being a real blocker
yeah I just think you should have put a
little more thought into this I mean
spread the prize around a little bit now
now what is one person gonna do with 206
iPhones yes I know exactly what I'm
going to do you can I said wait a minute
that's not my house see ya load up
another one John I know exactly what I'm
doing congratulations yeah best of luck
to you
you